to be happy and healthy they need to be
able to run and maybe just maybe this is
my role in this world is to provide that
for them
my name is TC Waite and I'm a dog musher
rescuing these dogs and giving them a
home is really important we have right
now 23 sled dogs on the property we kind
of have this motley crew of scratch and
dent sort of dogs that have come to us
from a variety of different places we
have a group of that have been rescued
we've got some from a shelter we've got
some retired racing sled dogs that are
living out their golden years with us in
my mind it's a second chance for these
dogs
yeah Huskies love to pull a sled it
keeps them active it keeps their mind
focused this is what they were bred to
do over generations even though they're
older or maybe they can't keep up with a
race team they still love to do it you
don't have to be the prima ballerina in
order to enjoy dance the way that we
make this work is we go back and forth
between Colorado and Alaska so in the
summer times we're down south in
Colorado and hold down jobs and save all
that we can during the summer so that we
can put it away towards towards the
winter we managed to transport 21 to 22
dogs over 3,000 miles each way twice a
year I've got friends and family they
might not understand our crazy little
life but they they understand that we're
doing good things for these dogs there
is nothing like experiencing a dog team
in action you're literally dropped into
this snow globe of wilderness that you
Explorer and you get to do it with your
best friends just makes my heart sing a
[Music]
certified Avalanche dog like tally can
do the work of about 30 rescuers in the
same amount of time their sense of smell
is 10 times the greater than ours and if
someone's buried in the snow are not
even buried but just lost in the woods
the dog can smell their scent coming up
through the snowpack and tell me where
to start digging to find that person we
are the first responders and a lot of
times if things go well and to our
training we can facilitate that rescue
without putting anybody else in harm's
way and be done quickly and efficiently
and I'll go home safely we gotta find
somebody I know you won't find somebody
okay let's go
my name is hunter Mortensen I'm
Avalanche technician here at
breckenridge ski resort with my ski
patrol partner Tali and we've been
working here for eight years together
we're really fortunate here at
Breckenridge we have six avalanche
rescue dogs on staff today
Tally's here and with her co-workers and
Friends is Boudreau the golden retriever
and a up another mountain purebred mutt
the years of the big st. Bernard and
Swiss Mountain Dog with the Beryl under
their neck those dogs are built for the
mountains they're sturdy they're Hardy
they can do it but what we're finding is
they don't travel low in the snow and
they're not as fast moving across the
snow and Avalanche rescue is all a
matter of time so we're looking these
days for dogs that are a little bit on
the smaller side a little more nimble
and a little more quick
so the training we stardom six to nine
months old and a lot of it is just basic
obedience and then we start building
from the obedience into actual
hide-and-go-seek type games and then we
build up from there into big snow caves
where we'll bury a person almost six
feet deep if we have enough snow and
then the dog will start searching having
to find where that sense coming up to
play the game and all they're really
looking for is that person who they
think has their toy it's about two full
years of training to take your last
certification test for an avalanche
rescue dog and handler so I'm certified
to work with tally my whole last eight
years of my career have been spent with
her every day all day when we have to do
our thing we're really dependent on each
other and I couldn't do what I do
without her and so it's an amazing
partnership and I'm really honored and
proud to be a part of this program and
work with the dog like her when I think
about the wilderness of Denali
I think of vastness and how small we are
in that great big wintry world
sled dogs are not the National Park
Service's idea this is an idea that we
have adopted from everyone else who knew
that dog teams were just the best most
reliable and I'd argue most fun way to
travel around Alaska in winter
[Music]
so I'm the kennels manager in Denali
National Park and Preserve and I'm in
charge of the only sled dog kennel in
the entire National Park Service in 1980
the original park boundary was
designated as wilderness and officially
designated wilderness is the highest
level of federal land protection
available and it means that you can't
use any motorized form of transport to
travel it's all going to be through non
motorized transport so dog-team skis
snowshoes anything like that chief these
dogs are all Alaskan Huskies born and
raised for thousands of years to live in
the harsh winter conditions of Alaska
and to want to run in pull a sled asking
me my favorite dog is like asking a
parent their favorite child it's not
possible to answer that question they
all win my heart in some way or another
these guys are amazing they bridge the
gap to the wild I think the dogs are
just an incredible invitation and
inspiration for our visitors we're all a
part of this wilderness we're all a part
of this place and it has so much to
offer us if we're willing to go out and
be challenged by Anna Littleton immerse
ourselves and it
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
in the peak of summer in Italy when the
beaches and lakes are full of swimmers
the lifeguards keeping everyone safe
bring in some much-needed assistance
[Music]
we're not matching pure superheat oy oy
oy oy - hola - hola knowing us all -
relationship when equipped enough to
connect the key for example son of a
hooch appealing gusano president and
optionally a squall italiana
conservative Joe in a 10 million which
in 2/10 ANOVA cuando yo present era
nobody know me master your pelota if you
are developing across the network since
then Ferruccio has found that dogs make
ideal lifeguard partners they remain
calm under pressure and instinctively
choose to save his path through the
water currents back to shore
once in the water they're able to keep
afloat birthda rescuer and the person in
need
yo is primarily LGA it we need
escalations to go to a pure PRT book
musical track appear disappear pianist
rita 7 o menos akane PFD I say persona
bustin cannon SI parla chica the benfica
taça de la no medium entity Danny the
link of the self attaches a molten photo
to keep up with these numbers the school
has over 350 certified rescue dogs and
each it takes a new recruits
[Music]
after about 18 months of training they
learn how to jump from speeding boats
and helicopters safely among other
rescue techniques Italy is the only
country in the world that recognizes
these certified canines as actual
lifeguards but the value of this is
catching on so the school is starting to
expand abroad soon can I be that answer
without doing push-ups I mean you don't
know Kenny's but yeah okay I mean they
are defense or dead Pedroni la piscine
second is drama teens de la causa the
samurai convinced any of you to be like
well lucky simply canít Pedroni any
momento de selva taja commissioned
compute with to oppose out kanima no
[Music]
pets love us unconditionally don't judge
us being up here and having a place for
the dogs makes all the difference in the
world
I know you're happy I'm glad dog
Mountain in the dog Chapel is an open
dog park where dogs can really connect
with nature and enjoy spending time
outdoors with their with their owners
and having a place like the dog chapel
really helps people say goodbye or also
just leave a little message about how
much they loved him it was basically
started by artist Steven eunuch and he
said the worst thing he'd ever heard is
it's just a dog
that's why Stephen built the dog Chapel
to memorialize these wonderful creatures
that have touched our lives so much
we've got people that pilgrimage from
every state and every continent just to
bask in the walls of the chapel and
leave a little message behind they take
comfort in knowing that those pictures
and those messages will be here for
years to come
I think dogs can bring out the best of
us and yeah it's it's horrific to say
goodbye but that's true of so many
losses in our lives there are some
places of reverence up here I think for
a lot of people however they choose to
recognize that dogs are really special
and it's one of a kind place that we
have here that allows dogs to really
shine and be cherished as the wonderful
little creatures that they are
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]